hello everyone and welcome to game five
of the world church championship 2021
between yanni palmishi and magnus
carlsen the first four games ended in a
draw but the first four games always end
in a draw this is now game five jan has
the white pieces and we'll see what
happens as tomorrow is again a rest
today so yeah maybe he strikes today and
then you know he enjoys his his rest day
uh but maybe not let's check out the
game and see what happened but as usual
i know you guys are really wondering uh
you know what happened with the
handshake this game so it was uh not all
that impressive here you can see magnus
uh arrives after yan yang gets up from
his chair and it was basically a
repetition from the handshake of the
handshake in game three so nothing out
of the ordinary uh magnus uh you know
matching the his uh uh suit with the
with the color of the pieces that he's
playing so he's shifting blacks through
the black pieces whites with white
pieces uh and that's pretty much it so
uh
that's uh that's what we have for the
handshake so we can enjoy that for uh a
little bit and the first move was made
by this gentleman it is sheikh nayan bin
mubarak al-nayan uh the minister of
tolerance and coexistence
and he chose the move c4
now nipple was not very impressed with
that he retracted the c4 move and you
can see that magnus is uh
very very uh interested in this move but
he knows that neville probably will not
go for the english but you know still
his mind wanders and you know he he does
have something prepared for it that's
that's for sure but nipple retracts this
c for pawn and he plays e4 that will we
see a repetition of what's been going on
in the previous games or something new
let's check it out magnus uh replies
with e5 we have knight to f3 knight to
c6 and now the ship to b5 so again uh we
have the the real opus so in the in the
first attempt of the rule lopez we've
had the uh sword of anti-marshall then
we had the anti-marshall and now i know
you guys are wondering will we see the
marshall uh let's uh see what uh what
was played a6
marshall magnus goes for the um
for the morphe defense with a6 we have
bishop to a4 knight to f6 castles and
bishop to e7 so repeating everything
from the previous games uh rook to e1
and the b5 now challenging the bishop on
a4 with bishop to b3 and here uh
we have uh castles by black uh and now
a4 so repeating uh game three uh but now
magnus doesn't go for bishop to b7 like
he played in game three but rather he
goes for rook to b8 and this is all very
standard stuff of the anti-marshall um
nothing and nothing new here uh so far
with eight captures on b5 a captures and
now h3 taking away that g4 square from
black's pieces and magnus goes d6
preparing to go bishop to e6 at some
point but we also have to
see that carlson's knight on c6 is
undefended so he has to be careful a
little bit otherwise this could be
you know taken advantage
of so here we have c3
magnus nipple preparing this d for push
and now you could play a lot of things
here you could play bishop to b7 you
could play bishop to e6 you could even
play maybe bishop to d6 uh d7 looks a
little bit weird but you could play it
but magnus of course goes for b4 this is
the essence of the position uh and he
wants to put pressure on nepal's very
strong center as nepal is preparing to
play d4 so here uh d4 uh would be uh
well it's just not all that promising
for white if you play d4 right away
magnus would just straight here for
example captures captures we could see a
capture here or we would see a capture
here now nipple with a very strong
center magnus could get his d5 move in
but now for example after e5 knight the
knight to e4 this is very uh very good
for for black niels grandelius mentioned
something about uh if you skip the move
rook to e1 and the rook is still on f1
maybe you can play something like knight
the e1 and then kick away the knight
with f3 not this exact same position but
sort of an idea of skipping the move
rook to e1 to avoid
getting such a position from black but
okay after b4 we have d3 uh you still
wait with d4 for the moment you're just
developing strengthening your center uh
we have b captures on c3b captures uh
and now uh okay the queen is guarding
the bishop so you don't have to worry
about that uh there is a game in the
database where knight to d7 was played
between yuri balashov and vs lavianosha
from 1992 but here in this game we have
d5 right away by magnus so it is now as
of move 13 that we have a completely new
game and now how do you react to this
well you most certainly don't capture
this this is kind of how chess works you
never capture and you always want your
opponent to capture and your opponent
wants the exact same thing so here if we
capture then we just improve the
position of
of black's pieces for example and
especially if we go after the pawn
knight captures knight captures and rook
captures that's sort of like accepting
the pawn in the martial attack or you
will simply allow black to develop
a lot and now you have this powerful
knight on d5 and now let's say you
capture here characters capture so we
can play bishop to e3
threaten this guy here but now black
plays c5 and you know it's a it's a very
much playable position where black has
the bishop pair and he pretty much
solved all of his developing problems
so not something nipple is eager to test
so instead after this d5 move uh sort of
the delayed marshall uh we have knight b
to d2 by nipple saying okay if you want
you capturing the center which magnus
does we have d captures an e4 d captures
on e4 and now we have bishop to d6 just
strengthening strengthening that e5 pawn
and magnus lost quite a lot of time here
nipple is still on almost two hours so
he didn't spend any time pretty much
reaching this position and magnus
already spent some half an hour
and here we have queen to c2 the real
question is why is magnus allowing
knight to c4 because it looks like such
a uh you know nice idea uh but it would
seem that magnus doesn't care about the
bishop there is a pawn on e5 so you
don't really expect this bishop to
become a powerful attacker and maybe
magnus would very uh be very happy if
knight captures pawn captures was played
so maybe he can play d5 at some point
and just uh you know get rid of that uh
lonely pawn on c7 uh so nipple doesn't
go for this instead after bishop to b6
he plays queen to c2 he just continues
development uh and now uh well now the
e4 pawn is guarded by the queen as well
so this is something to
also be taking into consideration we
have h6 by magnus uh and now we have
knight to f1 there was some talk of
nipple going g4 g5 or maybe you know
some sort of uh an aggressive attempt
against the black king uh but it doesn't
uh seem to be the case so here at knight
to f1 he wants to play knight to g3 and
get his knight all the way to f5 knight
to e7 magnus now with the exact same
idea maybe knight g6 the f4 can be
played knight to g3 we have knight to g6
and again nipple very very quickly
played bishop to e3 and uh you can see
that white's position is very very
enjoyable whereas crosstalk still has to
figure out how to
how to develop pretty much most of his
forces
and here uh carlson played a very
interesting move a queen to e8 and
magnus is already below uh the one hour
mark and it was still uh didn't spend
all that much time and i will just show
you how interesting the position is and
why it can be very dangerous if you
prepare your uh well yourself with very
strong engines as these guys and no
doubt are uh here the says the norwegian
supercomputer
suggests queen to e7 i will just show
this move because it's ridiculous i mean
you're basically inviting knight to f5
uh but the point is after white goes
knight to f5 which is the strongest move
you just go back queen to d8 this is how
super computers play chess and now
you're saying i will only now play
bishop to e6 because now uh
you already have a threat with the
knight on f5 you're threatening knight
captures on e4 after queen captures
you're gonna pick up the bishop on b3 so
here you're gonna move the bishop and
now we're gonna play bishop to e6 and
now the thing is after the bishop is
captured we're gonna double up our pawns
here to kick away the knight and after
knight capture c captures we get this
massive uh pawn mass in the center for
example rook e to d1 putting pressure on
the pawn as the queen is still on d8
queen to c7 we're gonna play rook to a6
put more pressure here rook after d8 and
now c4 and maybe stopping uh a move like
d5 but all in all a very enjoyable uh
position for black so uh it's a fine
position if you you know are able to
play like a super computer but uh if
you're not it can be uh it can be you
know very hard to play this so magnus
instead goes queen to e8 he wants to get
this bishop to e6 but he doesn't want to
allow the doubling of the pawn so he's
preparing to recapture with the queen uh
we have rook eat a d1 uh by nipple but
also there was a a very interesting move
here uh c4 c4 is the move that probably
could shift the the favor a little bit
over to the white side uh as you're
threatening c5 if black allows this it's
just not going to be very pleasant but
uh then again you know it's hard to say
for example if you play c5 uh it's not
all that all that great you're going to
play bishop a4 attack the queen and
after the queen moves rook e to d1 so uh
you know you can sense that white is uh
enjoying this position very much later
on you can maybe even bring this knight
over to
the d5 square is going to be a monster
knight uh the thing is after the c4
magnus could just play bishop to b4
attack the rook here and then after rook
e to d1 now play c5 himself and now it's
a bit of a different story because uh
well the bishop is not locked in there
on e7 but still the same idea can be
applied bishop to a4 let's say queen e7
now we can play bishop to c6 and place
the bishop on d5 instead of the knight
it's going to work just as well and this
is now a monster bishop
and black really never wants to capture
this and allow white to have a a
protected pass pawn such as this one or
you know capturing with the iphone
regardless uh
all depends on what black plays so it
would be uh very very unpleasant uh had
nipple went for c4 here but after queen
to e8 he played rook e to d1 you can see
that rook e to d1 was a very useful move
in both of the lines that started with
c4 so maybe he he's just preparing c4
but now magnus will not allow it now
magnus plays bishop to e6 uh puts
pressure on his uh
on the bishop on b3 and now c4 isn't all
that impressive because you can just
play queen to c6 and you don't have to
worry about such things uh you know
even if c5
then you even lose the game just bishop
captures and b3 but even if you didn't
have bishop captures on b3 the queen on
c2 is undefended so you know you can
never really capture so a c4 is no
longer an idea so here we have bishop a
for now attacking the queen and bishop
back to d7 and here we have bishop to b3
bishop to e6 bishop to a4 and bishop to
d7 and he was in this position on move
23 that they agreed to a draw that of
course is a joke of course they did not
agree to a draw on mu 22 after bishop to
d7 uh nipple continued with uh knight to
d2 he now wants to play knight to c4 as
this knight was you know bound to come
to c4 at some point in the game uh and
what do you play here well although
instead of this move you could maybe
avoid a trade you could play bishop back
to b3 but then we might see a repetition
or you could trade yourself on d7 if
captures captures and then c4 again it's
very nice if c5 can be played but queen
to c6 and you don't really care if c5
now again it's not really an issue you
can play basher back to e7 and now
maybe you can pile up on this pawn maybe
knight goes here attacks the pawn rook
goes here attacks the pawn uh who you
know who knows but it's it doesn't
appear to be a very good idea so instead
nipple goes knight to d2 he just wants
to keep the tension play knight to c4
put pressure on this bishop and now
magnus decides to trade everything
bishop captures an a4 and this is
usually the best course of action when
your opponent is controlling more space
and he has you know more uh wiggle room
on the board you want to of course trade
down as much as possible so queen
captures we have queen captures rook
captures and now even rook to a8 trading
off uh
rooks here we have rook beta a1 nipple
doubles up here we have captures
captures and now rook to b8 hoping to
get some action along the second rank uh
but now comes rook to a6 uh it seems
like for the moment uh maybe maybe not
the greatest of ideas um even though you
can't play rook to be to just put
pressure on the knight after knight to
c4 uh you're really not doing all that
much with that rook there you're uh the
rook is attacked also knight captures
bishop here is a threat so
uh it's uh you know not all that
impressive so uh what what you could do
instead uh after rook to a6 is you could
go knight to d7 that's definitely an
idea and after something like knight to
f5 go bishop to c5 just offer a trade of
bishops here for example g3 knight can
come to f8 and then after we see a trade
here for example captures captures 97
king h7 let's say something like rook to
a2 and then the game continues but this
is again
all very very powerful stuff from uh
from a a super engine uh in the actual
game magnus uh played knight to e8 uh he
now wants to bring this knight over here
or over here depending on what black
plays play f6 bring the king to f7 and
try to create some sort of a solid
structure before uh deciding on where to
go next and here came to f1 nepo starts
bringing the king into the game which
means the end game has officially
started uh but nepal also lost some time
he is now down to one hour whereas
magnus is down to some 40 minutes on the
clock we have knight to f8 uh bringing
one knight back is is a good move but
bringing two knights all the way back
that's you know world champion material
we have knight f5 uh an excellent square
for for nipples knight because now with
g6 you can simply eliminate the h uh
six pawn a uh h6 pawn so it's not really
uh you know uh possible uh knight to e6
by magnus and now knight to c4 putting
more pressure on that bishop on d6
we rook to d8 adding another defender
and now comes f3
so this is how nipple wants to play this
he wants to play g4 h4 h5 but there was
the idea of for example knight to g3 i
will show this again this is cesa's line
so uh very very strong stuff uh and
after black continues with the same idea
we're going to play h for now king f7
and now white starts bringing the king
into the game rook to b8 you want to
activate the rook here rook a5 taking
away the c5 square from black's pieces
and now bishop back to f8 you do not
want
white to have the option of capturing
whenever white wants h5
this is just grabbing more space on the
king side as one should do in an end
game and now activating the rook for
example rook to b1 and after knight to
f5 uh the idea is that if black goes
after the pawns you can play g4 and
after rook to g1 attacking this pawn you
can play game to f3 so white will get a
lot of expansion on the king side but he
will have a very passive king on f3 uh
so not really something to look at for
example knight d6 we're gonna see a
trade here captures bishop captures and
after knight capture c captures uh this
is the sort of uh well end game you get
rook a7 check king the e8 so white did
accomplish this he cut off the king from
entering the game he has a beautiful
pawn on h5 but other than that it
doesn't seem like the bishop will be all
that uh
you know of all that much use and you
can never start bringing the king into
the game because the g4 pawn now is
incredibly weak so
this is what you get with perfect play
so instead nepo discards that he plays
f3 we have f6 by magnus and now g4 we
have king to f7 as planned and now uh h4
preparing this h5 idea bishop to f8 so
not allowing this to be a target here
preparing knight to d6 king to e2 and
now comes knight to d6
we have knight c captures on d6 and now
it seems like a good idea to fix your
pawn structure by doing this but this
would weaken your position a little a
little too much because after rook to a7
check
you you can't really go uh uh at the g6
because then you have ideas like knight
captures and h6 and this is now very
annoying for example pawn captures and
h5 checkmate and you do not want to run
into something like that so after
something like uh this uh rook to a7
check you would have to go back king to
e8 and now you play something like king
to d2 and after well black plays uh
anything it would just be a very good
position for white the thing is uh the
central breakthrough with d5 is never an
option because of bishop to b6 and now
you ha you kind of have to move the rook
away and after you move the rook away we
can simply capture here and after you
capture here we're going to capture here
and after you capture here there's again
the tricky rook the g7 and the white is
most likely winning this it's it's not
going to be able uh he's not going to be
able to defend this uh with the black
pieces um it's just now uh to to destroy
the of
a pawn structure of course you can't
capture because then uh just captures
with check and there's a nice fork here
king of seven we're gonna capture here
captures and of course the king and pawn
end game is winning for white so uh even
though it seems like you should be
fixing your pawn structure uh you know
that's not always how you should be
thinking so bishop captures on d6 and
now nipple just pushes h5 with 30
minutes 35 minutes on the clock magnus
some 25 minutes on the clock uh let's
see how magnus now continues he goes
bishop back to f8 uh you need to add
additional support here but also you
never want white to be the one that has
this free pressure of just capturing
whenever he wants so rook to a5 now
taking away that c5 square from from
carlson's pieces and only now king back
to e8 we have rook to d5 offering a rook
trade uh which you could go for but for
example captures captures attacks the
knight knight goes back c4 c5 it's again
only white who's better here so after
rook to d5 we have rook to a8 and now
rook back to d1 we have rook to a to
check finally carlson's rook get gets
some activity but not near for just
blocks at rook d2 uh uh well you could
capture you know you don't really gain
anything by it and it's not like you you
have an advantage or anything so magnus
just played rookie one uh rook to d1
rookie to check we have brooke the d2 uh
of course time control has been reached
this is already move 42 so there's no
time pressure or anything rook to a1 we
rook to d1 and he was in this position
on mu 43 that the players agreed to a
draw
as you know there's uh really nothing
you you you can achieve here and no hope
for you know
doing in any more than you already have
so it was a very interesting game uh
magnus again uh chose a very tricky line
nipple didn't really care much about it
he just you know blitzed out moves and
got a very very comfortable position so
the real uh
the real moment where nipple probably
could have gone uh a little bit better
is this uh after carlson played this
queen to e8 uh movement instead of the
super computer queen e7 uh is this c4
line that we've mentioned uh going for
c5 but you know it's a very very hard
move to do because like we've shown even
if the pawn comes to c5 and you manage
to do this
if you don't if if this idea doesn't win
then most likely it's uh you know this
pawn will just be lost at some point so
uh maybe maybe that's why nepo decided
against it but uh it would seem that
this was
nepal's best bet of getting some uh
advantage here in game five so another
real lopez will we see a marshall in
game seven that's what everyone is
wondering or will it be another
uh repetition of this uh anti-martial
stuff with the h3 and the a4 and maybe
an early d3 without rook to e1 like like
uh
niels uh recommended so uh we'll see
what happens uh this is game five uh
already five draws in a row
and we'll see if this continues will we
have 14 draws or will we see uh some
blood uh because if we see one decisive
game then we're gonna see many decisive
games uh but you know without that one
uh you know it's it's very hard to
imagine that either of uh either of
players you know go for something wild
but you know it's still very early on uh
and players even though they're playing
incredibly precise now of course they
will get tired that they will be playing
for two weeks and then uh you know who
knows what will happen but that's why
we're here to enjoy it so let's see what
happens uh so once again hope you guys
enjoyed that uh i would like to thank
john anderson uh snakes maglise is bogus
uh christian schwartz uh shores phillip
uh and uh foreign for a contribution to
my channel thank you a lot i really
appreciate it as usual you can check to
my previous videos here thank you for
watching and i will see you soon
continuing the coverage of the world
chess championship until it ends uh
thank you i will see you soon and have
an excellent rest of your day